okay last week I did a fully detailed
breakdown of exactly how it is that the
YouTube algorithm is doing a lot to hurt
the David Pakman show
and last week I focused mostly on the
ways in which our traffic from YouTube
suggested video feed has fallen off of a
cliff and that story resonated with
people hugely the YouTube clip that we
did where I just explained here is how
the YouTube algorithm is crushing us
when it comes to suggesting our content
has surpassed 200,000 views in just a
few days and as a reminder in case you
didn't see that or you forgot about it
we used to regularly get about three and
a half million views per month from
YouTube including our content in the
suggested videos so this means that
you're browsing around content on
YouTube that is not david pakman show
content and alongside it orb down below
it YouTube will say hey here's some
stuff that you might like and some of
those clips are from the David Pakman
show we used to get as I said about
three and a half million views per month
from that algorithmic series of
suggestions that number dropped to
barely 1.5 million in June so the short
fall just in that bucket of views the
suggested content from YouTube is two
million views per month okay a drop of
two million views per month listen most
YouTube channels don't get two million
views a year nevermind per month and for
us our shortfall in views just from the
suggested video algorithm is about two
million views per month that's a huge
amount of revenue for us as I've said
before YouTube's terms and conditions
don't allow partners to talk
specifically about revenue but it's a
lot of money to lose two million views a
month just from that and what it appears
is happening is that YouTube is
recommending more establishment legacy
corporate channels over the David Pakman
show so whereas before if you went and
looked at a clip of whatever Stephen
Colbert along the side previously it was
more likely that a david pakman show
video would be recommended now it's more
likely that you're going to get
recommendations
from CNN from the other late-night talk
shows from establishment legacy
corporate sources so this is a direct
negative to independent media sources
like ours
I also last week alluded to another
piece of the problem and this is a
completely unrelated problem that's also
absolutely destructive and it makes me
wonder is YouTube trying to get me to
quit are they trying to get me to just
stop doing what we do and the problem is
what I would consider completely brand
safe videos with nothing controversial
nothing problematic nothing gory or
violent or anything like that
being demonetised individually this is a
double crush of the david pakman show
YouTube channel because on the one hand
YouTube is recommending our content less
frequently instead recommending
corporate legacy content and on the
other hand it's making it so that even
when our subscribers come to our channel
and watch our content more and more of
those videos aren't running ads meaning
that we end up earning no revenue from
those videos even when people do watch
them and this has now exploded in the
last three or four days with completely
innocuous videos being completely
demonetised and it's happening very
often to videos that do really really
well this next example should stun you
yesterday we did a story the story was
about Donald Trump's press conference
over the weekend in Japan the video was
called visibly sweaty Trump confused by
busing and liberalism the videos 9
minutes long it contains no profanity it
contains no descriptions of violence
it's not at all about anything gory
there's no gory images or vocabulary
there's no discussions of war or
terrorism or anything like it
there's no mention of race or racism in
the title in the description in the tags
it's two clips of Trump talking to
reporters Kristen Welker and I believe
Peter Alexander at a press conference in
Japan the video was instantly
demonetized when we uploaded it to
YouTube now this doesn't mean when it
published
it was demonetized
somebody complained about the video or
whatever the case may be before it even
published just when we uploaded it it
was automatically d monetized by
YouTube's algorithm here's a screenshot
the yellow dollar sign signifies that
the video has been marked as not brand
safe meaning we make no money from it
and despite YouTube's having told me a
couple of weeks ago that they will be
when we believe that the algorithm has
incorrectly identified a video as not
eligible for monetization they say you
press the appeal button and we're going
to try to review those appeals within an
hour or as close to it as possible 16
hours later as of this morning the video
still D monetized after 150,000 views in
the first 16 hours this is a really good
video for us 10,000 views an hour for 16
hours is a very solid for us and
completely lost revenue on it that we
will never regain we spend time
researching and gathering the clips we
prepare a commentary we edit the video
we uploaded it gets a bunch of views and
engagement and comments and we lose all
the revenue because of this D
monetization now let me be very clear
this is not about me thinking I have a
right to monetize on YouTube YouTube can
have a policy YouTube can monetize or D
monetize whoever they want assuming that
they're not for example targeting people
on the basis of their race or ethnicity
or religion if the as long as they're
not saying any videos done by people of
X race we will not monetize that I
believe would be against the law but I
have no right to YouTube ad revenue so I
don't want the Conservatives to
misunderstand my argument the problem is
we're playing the game the way YouTube
wants us to play it we're uploading
content that is not in violation of any
of the terms and conditions for
monetization I'm not even arguing that
this is a left versus right thing there
are left wingers who are having this
problem and there are right-wingers who
are having this problem if I had been
for example uploading videos where I am
bullying a specific youtuber or
journalist for their race or their
sexual orientation okay that I
understand if we were showing footage of
bloody
military conflicts even though by the
way I think it's actually good for us
not to be disconnected from the bloody
reality in the horrors of war I
understand that brands don't necessarily
want to advertise on videos that contain
violent war footage for example but it's
none of that and in the last month
YouTube has taken a decidedly anti
independent turn I believe that that's
what this is about they are suggesting
more and more corporate legacy videos
over independently produced videos in
news and politics they are monetizing
corporate legacy videos on the same
topics over which we are being
demonetised and now that a ton of you
have heard about this
many of you have fortunately said we're
not going to allow this to happen and I
have to thank you for that
June ended up being our biggest month
ever for new members and we have to keep
it going and I've run some numbers if we
have three more months of new members
like we had in June we will be able to
laugh away this D monetization issue and
we will be able to just do the content
and it won't matter what's monetized so
if you don't like what's going on here
and I know that there are people on both
sides of the political aisle that don't
like this just pick up a membership okay
this is really cheap
every person that signs up is giving us
immunity from this fiasco
every dollar we receive through
membership is a dollar we don't need or
have to worry about from YouTube we're
not going to go away assuming they don't
ban us okay make sure you subscribe to
our channel make sure you hit the bell
icon and tell YouTube you actually want
to be notified when we post video
content keep watching the clips and
please sign up for a membership if you
can it has not been going well on
YouTube lately but thanks to you we are
building a stronger foundation so we
will hopefully be less exposed to the
whims of the YouTube monetization
algorithm and by the way if you go to
david pakman.com slash membership and
the price is strike you is high for your
budget I totally understand that use the
coupon code this is 20 20 it'll chop 40%
off the cost of your membership let me
know what you think about this i'm on
instagram at david pakman the show on
instagram at david pakman show I will
keep you
of developments in this in this area
because I know that many of you do care
about what's going on